Soy de Detroit.
(Aplausos)
Una ciudad que en la década de 1950 era el gigante industrial del mundo,
con una población de 1.8 millones de personas
y 225 km2 de tierra e infraestructura,
usada para apoyar este centro urbano en pleno auge del medio oeste.
Y hoy,
solo medio siglo después,
Detroit es el ejemplo modélico de la decadencia urbana.
Actualmente en Detroit, nuestra población es de menos de 700 000,
de la cual el 84 % es afroestadounidense,
y debido a décadas de desinversión
y fugas de capital
de la ciudad a los suburbios,
hay escasez en Detroit.
Hay una escasez de venta al por menor,
más específicamente, venta al por menor de alimentos frescos,
dando como resultado una ciudad donde el 70 % de sus habitantes
son obesos y tienen sobrepeso,
y luchan.
Luchan por acceder a los alimentos nutritivos que necesitan,
que necesitan para mantenerse saludables,
para prevenir enfermedades prematuras y enfermedades relacionadas con la dieta.
Demasiados viven cerca de un restaurante de comida rápida
o de una tienda de conveniencia o una estación de servicio
donde tienen que comprar comida
usándola como un supermercado de servicio completo.
Y esta no es una buena noticia sobre la ciudad de Detroit,
pero esta es la noticia
y la historia
que los ciudadanos pretenden cambiar.
No, me corrijo.
Esta es la historia que los ciudadanos ya están cambiando,
a través de la agricultura urbana y el emprendimiento alimentario.
Esto es,
por la historia reciente de Detroit,
esta ahora se encuentra
con algunos recursos muy únicos,
siendo la tierra abierta uno de ellos.
Los expertos dicen que las ciudades enteras de Boston, San Francisco
y el barrio de Manhattan
cabrían en el área terrestre de la ciudad de Detroit.
Ellos también dicen que
esos 64 km2 de la ciudad están vacíos.
Eso es entre un cuarto y un tercio de la ciudad,
y con ese nivel de vacío,
tienen un paisaje diferente a cualquier otra gran ciudad.
Así que Detroit tiene esto: tierra abierta, tierra fértil,
proximidad al agua,
disposición a trabajar
y una demanda desesperada de alimentos saludables y frescos.
Todo esto ha creado un movimiento popular
impulsado por las personas de Detroit
que están transformando esta ciudad
de lo que fue la capital de la industria estadounidense
a un paraíso agrario.
(Aplausos)
Creo que de todas las ciudades del mundo,
Detroit, Michigan, es la mejor posicionada
para servir como ejemplo urbano del mundo
por la seguridad alimentaria y el desarrollo sostenible.
En Detroit hoy tenemos más de 1500, sí, más de 1500
jardines y granjas ubicadas en toda la ciudad.
Y no son parcelas de tierra
donde también cultivamos tomates y zanahorias.
La agricultura urbana en Detroit tiene que ver con la comunidad,
porque crecemos y cultivamos juntos.
Estos son espacios de convivencia.
Estos espacios son lugares donde estamos construyendo cohesión social
además de proporcionar alimentos saludables y frescos
a nuestros amigos, a nuestras familias y a nuestros vecinos.
Vengan conmigo.
Quiero llevarles por algunos vecindarios de Detroit,
y quiero que vean cómo es cuando se potencia el liderazgo local,
y cuando apoyas movimientos de base
de personas que están moviendo la aguja en comunidades de bajos ingresos
y personas negras.
Nuestra primera parada, Oakland Avenue Farms.
Oakland Avenue Farms se encuentra en el barrio North End de Detroit.
Oakland Avenue Farms se está transformando en un paisaje de dos hectáreas
que combina arte, arquitectura, ecologías sostenibles
y nuevas prácticas de mercado.
En el verdadero sentido de la palabra,
este es el aspecto de la agricultura en la ciudad de Detroit.
He tenido la oportunidad de trabajar con Oakland Avenue Farms
como anfitriona de cenas cultivadas en Detroit y cultivadas en la granja.
Estas son cenas en las que traemos gente a la granja,
les damos mucho tiempo y oportunidad
para conocer y saludar y hablar con el productor,
y luego los llevan a recorrer la granja.
Y luego reciben una comida de la granja a la mesa
preparada por un chef
que exhibe todo el producto de la granja justo en el mejor momento de su frescura.
Nosotros hacemos eso.
Traemos gente a la granja,
tenemos personas sentadas alrededor de una mesa,
porque queremos cambiar la relación de las personas con la comida.
Queremos que sepan exactamente de dónde viene su comida
que se cultiva en esa granja que está en el plato.
Mi segunda parada.
Voy a llevarles al oeste de Detroit,
al barrio de Brightmoor.
Brightmoor es una comunidad de bajos ingresos en Detroit.
Hay unos 13 000 residentes en Brightmoor.
Decidieron adoptar una estrategia cuadra por cuadra.
En el barrio de Brightmoor,
hay una microvecindad de 21 cuadras llamada Brightmoor Farmway.
Lo que era una comunidad claramente insegura y marginada
se ha transformado en una granja acogedora, hermosa y segura,
exuberante con parques y jardines y granjas e invernaderos.
Esta comunidad muy unida también se unió recientemente,
y compraron un edificio abandonado,
un edificio abandonado en mal estado y en ejecución hipotecaria.
Y con la ayuda de amigos, familiares y voluntarios,
pudieron derribar el cristal a prueba de balas,
pudieron limpiar los jardines
y transformaron ese edificio en una cocina comunitaria,
en un café, en una tienda.
Ahora los granjeros y los artesanos de la comida que viven en Brightmoor,
tienen un lugar donde pueden hacer y vender sus productos.
Y las personas en la comunidad
tienen un lugar donde pueden comprar alimentos frescos y saludables.
La agricultura urbana, y este es mi tercer ejemplo,
se puede usar como forma de elevar el modelo cooperativo comercial.
Las 1500 granjas y jardines de los que hablé antes,
y Keep Growing Detroit es una organización sin fines de lucro.
Esa tuvo mucho que ver con esas granjas.
Distribuyeron el año pasado 70 000 paquetes de semillas
y un cuarto de millón de trasplantes.
Y como resultado de eso el año pasado,
se cultivaron 250 000 kg de productos
en la ciudad de Detroit.
(Aplausos)
Pero aparte de todo eso,
también administran y operan una cooperativa.
Se llama Grown en Detroit.
Se compone de unos 70 agricultores,
pequeños agricultores.
Todos cultivan y venden juntos.
Cultivan frutas,
cultivan vegetales,
cultivan flores,
cultivan hierbas en un suelo saludable,
libre de químicos, pesticidas, fertilizantes,
productos genéticamente modificados...
comida sana.
Y cuando su producto se vende
en toda la ciudad de Detroit en los mercados locales,
obtienen el 100 % de los ingresos de la venta.
En una ciudad como Detroit,
donde mueren demasiados afroestadounidenses
como resultado de enfermedades relacionadas con la dieta,
los restaurantes juegan un papel muy importante
en aumentar el acceso a alimentos saludables en la ciudad de Detroit,
restaurantes culturalmente apropiados.
Entra en Detroit Vegan Soul.
Sí, tenemos un restaurante de comida vegana en la ciudad de Detroit.
(Aplausos)
Sí, sí.
Detroit Vegan Soul está brindando a los residentes la oportunidad
de comer más alimentos a base de vegetales
y han recibido una respuesta abrumadora de los habitantes de Detroit.
Los habitantes de Detroit tienen hambre de lo culturalmente apropiado,
comida fresca y deliciosa.
Por eso creamos una organización sin fines de lucro llamada FoodLab Detroit,
para ayudar a los emprendedores de alimentos del vecindario
a iniciar y expandir empresas de alimentos saludables.
FoodLab proporciona incubación a estos empresarios,
educación práctica, talleres,
asistencia técnica, acceso a expertos de la industria
para que puedan crecer y expandirse.
Son negocios muy pequeños,
pero el año pasado, tuvieron un ingreso combinado
de más de USD 7,5 millones,
y proporcionaron 252 trabajos.
Escuchen.
(Aplausos)
Estos son solo algunos ejemplos
sobre cómo se expanden oportunidades
para que todos puedan participar
y prosperar,
particularmente aquellos que vienen de vecindarios
que históricamente han sido excluidos de este tipo de oportunidades.
Lo sé, lo sé.
Mi ciudad está muy lejos de tener éxito.
Todavía estamos luchando,
y no voy a decir aquí en este escenario
que todos los problemas de Detroit y todos los desafíos de Detroit
van a ser resueltos a través de la agricultura urbana.
No voy a hacer eso,
pero diré lo siguiente:
la agricultura urbana hace que Detroit piense en su ciudad
de una manera diferente,
una ciudad que puede ser tanto urbana como rural.
Y sí, lo sé, estas historias son pequeñas,
estas historias son historias con base en vecindarios,
pero estas historias son poderosas.
Son poderosas porque muestran cómo creamos una nueva sociedad
dejado atrás los lugares y los espacios que se desintegraron.
Son historias poderosas porque son historias sobre el amor,
el amor que los habitantes de Detroit sienten el uno por el otro,
el amor que sentimos por la comunidad, el amor que sentimos por la Madre Tierra,
pero más importante, estas historias son historias
sobre cómo la devastación, la desesperación, la decadencia
nunca tienen la última palabra en la ciudad de Detroit.
Cuando cientos de miles de personas salieron de Detroit,
y nos dieron por muertos, los que se quedaron tenían esperanza.
Se aferraron a la esperanza.
Nunca se rindieron.
Siempre siguieron luchando.
Y escuchen, lo sé,
transformar una gran ciudad como Detroit en una ciudad próspera,
funcional, que sea saludable,
que sea inclusiva, que ofrezca oportunidades para todos,
sé que es difícil,
sé que es un desafío, sé que es difícil.
Pero solo creo
que si comenzamos a fortalecer el tejido social de nuestras comunidades,
y si damos oportunidades económicas en nuestros barrios más vulnerables,
todo comienza con saludable, accesible,
deliciosa comida culturalmente apropiada.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.